[Musique]
du coup d'état du 18 brumaire qui amène
napoléon bonaparte au pouvoir jusqu'à la
chute de l'empereur en 1814 le palais du
luxembourg a joué un rôle crucial dans
cette période clé de l'histoire de
france
les grandes étapes du régime napoléonien
ont été imaginés en tout cas toujours
validé par le sénat conservateur dans ce
palais le sénat conservateur créé en
1799 s'installe au palais du luxembourg
qui se métamorphose pour l'occasion avec
l'arrivée de napoléon pouvoir le palais
du luxembourg va subir sa première
grande transformation
ce palais qui était un palais à
d'habitation pour les princes pour les
rois va devenir un lieu où va siéger une
assemblée législative
longtemps décrié pour sa docilité ou au
contraire pour avoir déchu l'empereur en
1814 le sénat conservateur a en tout cas
été au coeur des institutions pendant
les quinze années où napoléon à
gouverner la france
en protégeant les institutions
d'atteinte à leur fonctionnement
régulier et en à quart-temps napoléon du
pouvoir le sénat a réussi à permettre la
continuité de l'état
le sénat où fonds est un des grands
acteurs du régime napoléonien peut-être
le plus méconnu
[Musique]
nous sommes ici dans l'allée qui mène du
palais du luxembourg proprement dit est
ce qu'on appelle le petit luxembourg qui
était à la fin de la révolution entre
1795 1799 le siège du pouvoir exécutif
tenue par cinq directeurs parmi ces
directeurs l'abbé emmanuel sieyès
préparer un coup d'état parlementaire
pour renforcer le pouvoir exécutif dans
la constitution et rendre les
institutions plus fluide eux
fonctionnent en mieux et c'est donc ici
que à son retour d'égypte en octobre
1799 bonaparte a rencontré on va dire
pour la première fois l'abbé sieyès et
c'est dans ces locaux du petit
luxembourg qu'ils ont préparé le coup
d'état des 18 et 19 brumaire de l'an 8
un coup d'état pensée de longue date et
pour lequel napoléon bonaparte n'était
pas le premier choix mais le général
s'impose vite comme l'homme de la
situation
reste à convaincre les chambres
parlementaires le coup d'état du 18
brumaire devait être un coup d'état
purement parlementaire ont fait croire
aux chambres qu'un complot jacobins les
menaces ont fait nommer bonaparte à la
tête de la garnison de paris et les
chambres décident de se réunir en dehors
de la capitale comme le prévoit la
constitution au château de saint-cloud
le deuxième jour du coup d'état le 19
brumaire on essaye d'obtenir des
chambres le vote de la révision de la
constitution et bonaparte perd patience
et finalement après une bousculade dans
un des deux conseils
il fait intervenir la troupe est expulsé
les députés ce coup d'état parlementaire
devient un coup d'état militaire mais
redevient un coup d'état parlementaire
puisque on fait revenir les chambres en
séance et c'est là qu'elle vote la fin
du directoire et demande le vote d'une
nouvelle constitution
dès le lendemain le 11 novembre 1799
napoléon s'installe au palais du
luxembourg depuis 1795 c'est le lieu du
pouvoir
la douce gouverne la france
nous allons entrer dans les salons
boffrand du nom de son architecte c'est
ici que siéger le directoire exécutif de
1795 à 1799 donc c'est ici qu'a été
gouverné la france à la fin de la
révolution
le directoire n'était pas un régime très
populaire il a connu beaucoup d'échecs
d'abord la constitution fonctionnaient
mal un coup d'état par an en moyenne
les finances publiques étaient exemple
l'administration locale
inexistante et puis surtout la guerre
civile continuer à l'intérieur et la
guerre extérieure était très vive elle
aussi en allemagne et en italie
en italie le général napoléon bonaparte
s'illustre dans les batailles face aux
autrichiens jusqu'à leur faire signer la
paix en 1797 mettant fin à cinq années
de guerre
c'est auréolé de gloire qu'il revient à
paris en 1797 napoléon bonaparte rentrer
de la campagne d'italie et il est reçu
ici au palais du luxembourg
solennellement par le directoire à qui
il doit remettre le texte du traité de
campo formule le directoire reçoit
bonaparte avec tous les honneurs parce
que il faut savoir aussi que bonaparte
est déjà connu et déjà un peu populaire
donc c'est une façon de de capter la
gloire qu'il a obtenu en italie et puis
surtout de montrer au peuple qu'on
accepte ce traité de campo formule qui
au départ n'a pas fait très plaisir aux
directeurs parce que car général se
substituer au gouvernement et au
ministre de l'intérieur pour négocier la
paix ça n'était quand même pas habituel
à cette époque le directoire chargera
ensuite napoléon d'envahir l'egypte
ce n'est qu'au retour de cette
expédition que sieyès fera de bonaparte
son homme de main pour le coup d'état
une fois le directoire renversé il faut
mettre en place une nouvelle
organisation
c'est dans les salons du palais du
luxembourg que vont être débattues les
principes du consulat la première tâche
qui a été assigné au consul provisoire
c'est de rédiger une constitution et
c'est dans ce salon que vont se réunir
deux commissions législatives en
présence des consuls et elles vont
travailler pendant un petit mois à la
rédaction de la nouvelle constitution
dite constitution de l'an 8
et c'est là que bonaparte va intervenir
il va laisser à sieyès la partie
législative qui l'intéressent peu mais
va beaucoup s'occuper de la partie
concernant le pouvoir exécutif
avec évidemment les plus grands pouvoirs
la principale liberté qui sera donné au
futur consul sieyès a donc le champ
libre sur la partie institutionnelle
dès le titre 2 de la constitution le
sénat conservateur est créé avec un rôle
majeur à la clé la grande innovation de
la constitution de la 8c la création de
ce sénat conservateur au sens de
conservateurs de la constitution
c'est une idée de sieyès qui
souhaitaient une assemblée de sages qui
puisse surveiller l'application du texte
fondamental arbitrer les différends et
même exercer un contrôle de
constitutionnalité des lois et des
textes de l'exécutif
[Musique]
en plaçant le sénat conservateur aussi
haut dans la constitution les rédacteurs
veulent marquer son rôle de garant d
autres institutions très clairement et
une volonté honorifique
d'une part et aussi très symbolique
mettre en avant les sénateurs en tant
que tel comme étant des garants du bon
fonctionnement des institutions et
d'autre part s'assurer du fait que l'on
vise justement à stabiliser les
institutions le sénat conservateur a
l'ascendant sur les chambres
législatives c'est lui qui est chargé de
désigner ses membres par un suffrage
indirect
les pouvoirs sont effectivement
considérable le premier d'entre eux
c'est se substituer à l'élection puisque
ce sont les sénateurs qui vont désigner
la plupart des personnes amenées à
travailler au sein des institutions
publiques et notamment au sein du corps
législatif du tribunat etc etc
les membres du sénat sont au départ
nommé par siess les autres consul puis
par une formule de cooptation ils sont
au début du régime 80 et vont donc se
voir assigner comme siège le palais du
luxembourg
[Musique]
fin 17 199 commencent alors les grands
travaux au palais du luxembourg peu
retouché depuis sa construction pour
marie de médicis au xviie siècle le
grand palais va être totalement
transformé nous sommes donc en 1799 et
un napoléon vient de créer le sénat
conservateur
on va confier à chalgrin qui est
architecte d'état la double mission de
rénover entièrement le palais mais aussi
de le changer
structurellement afin que cet édifice
qui était jusque là une habitation royal
deviennent un bâtiment administratif
[Musique]
le premier chantier de chagrin va être
d'offrir à ces nouveaux sénateurs une
entrée digne de ce nom
il va complètement évident et c'est elle
ou est celle là même qui abritait les
appartements de marie de médicis est
installé à la place cet escalier
monumental monumental par ses dimensions
nous sommes ici devant 48 marche juste
entrecoupé d'un palier de repos il faut
bien comprendre que chaque marche est
construite d'un seul pan de pierre large
de 7 m imaginez le travail que ça a pu
représenter pour l'installer
[Musique]
chalgrin va utiliser quelques éléments
de décor pour donner une touche
d'orientalisme à l'ensemble c'est à dire
qu'il va faire installer des lions de
nubie des lions qui sont sans cris
wierre et qui viennent de l'egypte
ancienne
il va aussi installés tout autour de
l'escalier une frise sculptée qui
reprend des éléments de décor qui
proviennent de la grèce et de la rome
ancienne on retrouve dans le haut de
l'escalier d'honneur le style antique
emprunté par chalgrin il va utiliser 28
colonnes d'ordre ionique pour tenir la
voûtes majestueuses qu'il vient de créer
cette voûte est composé de 308 rosas en
caisson
[Musique]
nous rentrons maintenant dans le coeur
des transformations réalisées par
chalgrin cette grande salle était à
l'époque divisée en trois parties
nous avons ici une salle de réunion
c'est une salle qui permet aux sénateurs
de se réunir c'est un vestibule avant
d'entrer dans la salle des séances
il y avait un grand mur sur lequel était
apposé un portrait de plain pied de
napoléon
car si l'empereur n'était pas toujours
présent lors des séances ça voulait
quand même dire que chaque sénateur qui
allaient pénétrer dans la salle des
séances le faisait sous le regard de
l'empereur la porte se situer sur le
côté droit du mur vous n'aviez qu'à la
pousser et vous rentriez directement
dans la salle des séances
au coeur de cette salle chalgrin réussi
à aménager un hémicycle pouvant
accueillir 80 puis 120 sénateurs à
partir de 1800 2,26 colonnes en marbre
soutiennent l'édifice ou des statues
antiques décor l'ensemble dans le plus
pur style néoclassique face au travail
des sénateurs au coeur de la pièce dans
un renfoncement créé spécialement
chalgrin installe le trône de l'empereur
un trône surmonté d'un dea de forme
circulaire soutenus par six cariatides
de plus de deux mètres de haut
drapé à l'antique si le des a depuis
quitté le palais le trône est lui
toujours dans la salle qu'il accueillait
à l'époque
l'inspiration orientale est évidemment
présente puisqu'il repose sur deux
sphinx aux ailes déployées sur le
velours le n napoléonien et l'abeille
rappelle les emblèmes de celui qui
deviendra empereur en 1804
[Musique]
nous arrivons maintenant dans la
dernière pièce de cette enfilade qui fut
aussi la dernière créé puisque on estime
qu'elle est terminée
en 1809 cette salle on va la nommer le
salon de l'empereur ou la salle des
victoires on retrouve que ce soit dans
la voûte ou sur les murs des peintures
qui relate les victoires napoléoniennes
mais la pièce la plus importante que
l'on trouve ici va se trouver à ce qui
est aujourd'hui la porte du salon victor
hugo c'est là qui est installé l'immense
statue représentant napoléon elle fait
plus de deux mètres de haut et il est
habillé avec les apparats du sacre le
sénat conservateur a donc désormais un
palais aménagé pour travailler
en l'an 1800 napoléon bonaparte quitte
le palais du luxembourg pour emménager
aux tuileries
il pose les premières pierres d'un état
moderne en créant la banque de france et
la fonction de préfet relais du pouvoir
dans les départements mais à la fin de
l'année 10 800 un tournant va changer la
donne pour napoléon comme pour le sénat
conservateur en décembre 1800 napoléon
et échappe à un attentat
il désigne comme coupable les jacobins
et dessine que 130 d'entre eux vont être
transportés aux colonies l'attentât raté
de la rue saint-nicaise va provoquer un
dilemme moral car contrairement à ce que
pense napoléon ce ne sont pas les
jacobins qui ont tenté de le tuer mais
des royalistes
même une fois les véritables coupables
arrêtés napoléon veut profiter de ce
moment pour purger l'opposition jacobine
trop remonte à ce moment c'est un acte
qui va contre la liberté publique et
donc cambacérès le numéro deux du régime
lui propose de d'interroger le sénat sur
la constitutionnalité de cette mesure
l'attentât de la rue saint-nicaise est
vraiment le tournant politique juridique
du consulat indéniablement on était dans
une situation d'illégalité la plus
totale puisque on souhaitait des portes
et des personnes qui n'étaient en rien
responsable de l'attentât qui visait le
premier consul alors le sénat va
travailler pendant une grosse journée
sur le sujet et va approuver l'action du
gouvernement sous forme de ce qu'on a
appelé un sénatus consulte qui était une
vieille procédure romaine et c'est à
partir de là que le sénat a pu s'arroger
presque le pouvoir constituant dérivé
qui lui sera accordée formellement par
la constitution la réforme
constitutionnelle de l'an 10 en 1802
deux ans après son arrivée au pouvoir
napoléon bonaparte à stabiliser le pays
sur le plan intérieur le concordat signé
pacifiant les relations avec l'église
catholique
sur le plan extérieur la france signe
avec l'angleterre la paix d'amiens au
front la première période de paix totale
depuis plus de dix ans
les chambres législatives veulent saluer
ce moment en donnant au premier consul
un signe de reconnaissance en le nommant
conçu la vie mais le sénat conservateur
est mesurée dans un premier temps le
sénat n'est pas d'accord avec ce projet
et il le fait savoir puisque il vota
premier texte dans lequel en réalité le
pouvoir de bonaparte ne prolonger que de
10 ans et puis c'est finalement avait
après un bras de fer entre les sénateurs
et le gouvernement que sera adopté le
sénatus consulte de l'andi ce qui
modifie assez profondément la
constitution et parmi les mesures qui
sont prises il y en a deux qui intéresse
le sénat la première c'est sa défaite
puisque bonaparte est nommé consul à vie
mais la deuxième c'est un peu sa
victoire puisque le sénat voit ses
pouvoirs renforcés
le nombre de sénateurs augmenté on va
donner au sénat des outils qu'ils
n'avaient pas en l'an 800 pour qu'il
n'utilisera jamais d'ailleurs mais qui
lui permettent justement d'être le
garant effective de la constitution
clairement il a maintenant une île est
vraiment un garant de la constitution
mais un garant outillés et efficace
cette pratique qu'on va appeler celle
des senatus consult qui va être de la
part du sénat dans son rôle de
conservateur de la constitution une
mission d'interprétation de la
constitution voire même à un moment
donné de modification de la constitution
ce qu'on appelle le pouvoir constituant
dérivé qui n'était pas prévue dans la
constitution et que l'on va remettre au
sénat qui lui assure s'en saisir
[Musique]
le sénat ne cesse donc de voir son rôle
grandir et pour assurer de bons revenus
à une partie des sénateurs en 1803 on
leur attribue de grand palais des
domaines situés aux quatre coins de
france les sénatorerie pour beaucoup on
achète ainsi la docilité des sénateurs
mais pas seulement au début du consulat
ce qu'il veut simplement c'est recréer
une élite sociale qui a été très
largement déstructuré par la période
révolutionnaire
en créant ces structures que sont les
sénateurs mais on peut ainsi s'assurer
d'avoir une élite qui est au service de
l'état qui s'insèrent aussi localement à
travers la propriété foncière et la
propriété terrienne qui éventuellement
d'ailleurs se lit familialement avec les
élites locales de façon bien plus
efficace que ne le sont les préfets en
1804 après quatre années de pouvoir de
napoléon bonaparte les bases du régime
sont posées
le consulat vit ses derniers jours et
napoléon bonaparte se rêve en empereur
des français
une fois encore c'est le sénat qui va
assurer la rédaction d'une nouvelle
constitution
contrairement à ce qu'on dit souvent
napoléon n'est pas devenu empereur le 2
décembre 1804 au moment de son sacre
mais le 18 mai 1804 au moment où le
sénat a voté à sénatus consulte
transformant le consulat en empire le
sénat est le seul à pouvoir permettre le
passage à l'an pire puisqu'il est devenu
officiellement le garant des
institutions certes mais surtout
l'acteur principal de la modification
constitutionnelle
donc on ne pouvait pas envisager autre
chose qu'un système de passation par le
sénat alors on pense toujours que les
choses sont passés comme une lettre à la
poste comme on dirait populairement mais
en réalité ça a été très difficile
la procédure a été complexe et surtout
au sénat il y a eu des débats de
véritables débats avec des discours de
sénateurs qui bien qu acceptant lempire
le rendait conditionnelle ils sont en
partie à l'origine du serment impériale
qui relativise cette idée que
l' empire met à mal toute idée de
conservation des institutions bien au
contraire
l'empereur et ses descendants s'engage à
respecter les principes fondamentaux
ayant conduit au système consulaire est
impérial
ces conditions se retrouve d'ailleurs
dans le serment constitutionnel que
l'empereur a prêté justement le 2
décembre 1804 à notre dame
notre dame de paris et le théâtre de ce
couronnement le 2 décembre 1804 le pape
est présent pour bénir ce sacre napoléon
bonaparte devient napoléon 1er empereur
des français mais comme prévu par les
sénateurs l'empereur prête serment de
préserver une grande partie des acquis
de la révolution liberté de culte
liberté politique levée de l'impôt par
les chambres législatives est de
gouverner dans le seul intérêt du peuple
français
la constitution de 1804 qui installe
lempire prévoit que le régime est
héréditaire le rôle des assemblées est
clairement amoindri mais le sénat
obtient tout de même la création de
première commission censée garantir les
libertés les plus fondamentales
indéniablement les commissions sont dans
la dans le prolongement du contrôle de
constitutionnalité et de l'idée que le
sénat est une sorte d' oracle de ce qui
doit être le bon fonctionnement de
l'état elles ont pour vocation de
contrôler finalement toutes les
atteintes qui seraient portés aux
principes fondamentaux que sont la
liberté individuelle et la liberté la
presse il s'agit donc éventuellement
d'ordonner la publication d'organes de
presse qui aurait été interdit mais
aussi de demander l'élargissement de
personnes qui seraient injustement
enfermé
pendant les dix années que dure lempire
le sénat se réunit beaucoup moins et se
contentent souvent de valider les
demandes de l'empereur ce sont ainsi les
sénateurs qui votent les conscriptions
qui permettent de fournir à la grande
armée les troupes nécessaires aux
guerres napoléoniennes en retour
napoléon n'oublie jamais de remercier
les sénateurs ceci est la plaque dit
delfingen cette plaque rappelle que
napoléon a déposé au sénat après la
campagne de 1805 une grande partie des
drapeaux pris à l'ennemi le reste allant
aux corps législatif au tribunal ou aux
invalides
cette plaque rappelle aussi que le sénat
a joué un rôle dans cette campagne
puisque grâce aux sénatus consulte il a
permis d'augmenter la conscription et
d'augmenter finalement les effectifs de
l'armée française c'est aussi une façon
pour napoléon de distribuer la gloire
auprès des grandes institutions civiles
afin que cette gloire soit véritablement
celle de la nation pendant près de dix
ans personne ne remettra en question la
vision de l'empereur du moins tant que
les victoires s'enchaînent mais
l'invasion de la russie en 1812 fini par
tourner à la berezina
en 1814 la france est acculé les armées
étrangères envahissent paris napoléon
est reclus à fontainebleau est allé
rendement dos et nate de porter le coup
de grâce le 2 avril 1814 les sénateurs
peaufine mot par mot leur dernier
sénatus consulte dans les archives du
sénat on retrouve le brouillon à noter à
la main ou les sénateurs liste
l'ensemble des griefs qui les pousse à
déchoir napoléon 1er le 3 avril en
séance
il acte cette déchéance de l'empereur le
cdh a tu consultes explique que napoléon
n'a pas respecté son serment
constitutionnel et donc par conséquent
le sénat ne peut que constater la
déchéance
de l'empereur l'acte de déchéance c'est
un vrai modèle d' analyse contentieuse
d'une situation
les sénateurs avaient peur qu'on leur
reproche l'absence de fondement pour
cette décision malheureusement on n'a
absolument pas retenu ce problème de la
justification juridique pour se
concentrer sur la situation politique et
la trahison
au fond les sénateurs n'avaient pas
tellement le choix le territoire
national était occupée napoléon était
maintenue à fontainebleau avec très peu
de troupes
il fallait sortir de cette crise je
dirais avec une solution française et
non pas une solution imposée par les
vainqueurs de napoléon et c'est pourquoi
le sénat après avoir été le grand
complice de napoléon a accepté d'être le
grand complice de talleyrand à
fontainebleau napoléon rumine contre ce
sénat qui s'est retourné contre lui mais
il n'a d'autre choix que d' abdiquer le
6 avril 1814
les vainqueurs l'envoi en exil sur l'île
d'elbe tandis que le sénat appelle aux
pouvoirs louis xviii frère du roi louis
saez décapiter la monarchie et restaurer
le sénat est remplacé par la chambre des
pairs il perd sa mission de contrôle
constitutionnel pour devenir une
véritable chambre législative
le sénat a probablement permis dans son
fonctionnement et dans tout simplement
dans son existence de poser des piliers
fondateurs de notre france contemporaine
comme par exemple l'université
le code du commerce comme le code pénal
ou alors tout simplement comme le code
civil
au fond ce qui reste surtout de ce sénat
là c'est l'idée d'une assemblée de sages
d'abord plus âgé il fallait avoir 40 ans
pour être sénateur soulan pire non
soumis aux pressions extérieures ou
pression de la politique du quotidien
c'est peut-être un petit peu autour de
cette idée qu'on pourrait trouver une
filiation entre le sénat de napoléon et
le sénat de la vème république
[Musique]